just the other day we saw what may be
the most extreme violence I've seen from
antifa and the far left I've been
covering this stuff for over a decade
and what happened in Georgia is
as an act of Terror and it escalates
beyond anything we've seen thus far and
I don't know what word to use to
describe it but protest demonstration
don't cut it terror attack is probably
the best you can get but it's probably a
bit more than that when a terrorist
faction you know commits an attack
usually it's some cell somewhere with
some weird Fringe ideology you've never
heard of and they're like oh there's a
terror attack right some far-off group
from a far away land now this time it's
a National Organization with national
institutions backing them all over the
country converging in Georgia to lay
Siege to a government facility fire
bombing Vehicles destroying things
previously shooting a cop and putting in
the hospital so call it whatever you
want we're now hearing that the cop City
Insurgency or terror attack involved
people from France Canada and one of the
people arrested was a was a lawyer it's
being reported with the Southern Poverty
Law Center so
um this one's pretty crazy 35 people I'm
not going to say you know all all news
media is trying to say oh they were
arrested at a protest and I'm kind of
like I I think we're well beyond that so
I put captured and the reason I did for
those that are looking at the title
saying captured what does that mean well
you've got foreign individuals here who
are attacking American government
facilities I don't think you'd say you
arrested a foreign individual who was
attacking your country capture it sounds
more appropriate but we'll talk about
that plus in uh line with social and U.S
Decay we've got more stories Anthony
fauci in a newly uncovered email appears
to well I'll put it this way
it looks like he commissioned a study to
discredit lab League theory he himself
then later cited that study saying see
look lab leak isn't uh it's not a thing
and the media of course just marched in
lockstep alongside the so let's talk
about all the stuff that's going on plus
we got some other stories things might
get a little bit spicy Joe Rogan saying
he'd probably rather vote for Trump over
Biden at this point he said something
similar in the past and Joe Biden said
uh his brain wasn't all there and the
doctors had to pop open his skull to see
if it was still working
yeah okay it seems like things are
falling apart before we get started my
friends head over head over to
timcast.com and click that join us
button you see we've got some more stuff
to talk about tonight in terms of social
Decay but we have to bring that over to
the members only uncensored live show
which will go up around 10 10 p.m so
once we wrap this live show on YouTube
we will have a Live members only show at
timcast.com and we'll be talking about
things that are not so family friendly
and not so family-friendly ways if you
want to support the work we do become a
member at timcast.com because you're our
customer you know we we don't have that
many sponsors I typically don't like
picking up sponsors because I don't want
these corporations to be my customer I
want you to be my customer that means we
are here to work for you it also means
we need your support by becoming a
member at timcast.com but also you can
smash that like button subscribe to this
YouTube channel share the show with your
friends or if you can that's the most
powerful way to help other than being a
member and uh well that's about it
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this and a whole lot more is Martina
marcona
thank you who are you what do you do
well I was was a burlesque performer in
New York City I worked in the
entertainment nightlife industry
in New York City and then I got canceled
so that's quite a story with the
canceling and
how the culture has shifted starting
from 2016 and I know that there was a
lot going on that built up to that in
2016 but that was I feel like
the Crux of of our societal separation
and then
um
you know the importance of art and
culture and where where I think we need
to uh
head from here instead of just focusing
on being canceled I want to talk about
what we can do yeah you uh were saying
before the show that people used to know
that you voted Republican it was no big
deal but then all of a sudden this like
fissure happens
yeah I mean everyone knew all my friends
knew I was a voter Republican they had
no problems with it they just thought it
was like oh she's a little kooky over
there about her politics whatever not a
big deal but as soon as I got
you know outed for supporting Trump and
we all know what this is like right in
2016 it was like
like how did
Trump just like changed the game the way
that everyone focused on politics and it
just like became you're either an evil
Nazi Trump supporter or you're the good
guy and even all my friends were just
like you're an evil Trump supporter now
well we'll get into all that so this
should be interesting thanks for joining
us we got Phil Labonte hanging out hello
everyone I am uh Phil Labonte lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and I'm Ian Crossland at Ian
crossland.net you can find me there uh
let's keep moving what's happening Serge
yeah I am search.com as always ready to
go all right well let's just jump into
this first story we got this from Fox
News Atlanta cop City Anarchy Sees at
least 35 agitators detained part of an
International Group suspects from France
Canada and out of Georgia among those
arrested in significant escalation at
Atlanta's police and fire training
facility we got a video here from Andy
no on YouTube which I will play Just
portion of so you can see just some of
the scale of this degree of extremism
this is a government facility there's
there's what looks like power lines
construction equipment and hordes of
people running in and ransacking things
now of course you've got many on the
left trying to claim that it's not
organized it's just a demonstration it
was all impromptu blah blah blah but
that is absolutely not true you have
people who have been occupying this
location for years you have an
individual who was killed by cops after
shooting a cop
people who have burned down houses one
private citizen had his truck set on
fire and flipped over these are
extremists who have been occupying this
area for some time they brought in guns
from across state lines believe it or
not I know I know
shocking isn't it and they organized
this they are ransacking another
government facility they are funded this
is look at these videos I mean some of
this is crazy huge groups of people and
they're calling it
they're calling it a demonstration I
think Fox News even calls it this they
say
a group of agitators
left the nearby South River Music
Festival around 5 30 p.m and descended
on the construction site of the pros
Atlantic Atlanta Public Safety Training
Center to conduct a coordinated attack
on the construction equipment and police
officers
all right here's the issue here's why I
won't call it a demonstration here's why
I'll say it's organized here's why I
won't say these people were arrested you
see what Fox News says 35 detained I
guess detained is better than arrested
an arrest is when like a hippie marches
in the middle of the street waving a
little flag or sign and they say sir you
are obstructing a roadway and he says we
gotta end the war and they're like if
you don't leave the road you're getting
arrested he says I refuse they arrest
him bring him to the station he gets a
slap on the wrist they let him go that's
an arrest
when you have outside forces from
foreign countries and people coming from
across the across the United States
under a shared Banner flying a flag of
an active organization with websites to
recruit people receiving funding who has
previously been engaged in Insurgency
and Terror attacks like that guy in
Washington who said he was antifa and
firebombed the nice facility I am sick
of them Fox News everybody constantly
downplaying it and being like no no no
everything's fine because I will say
this before we get into the bigger
conversation
you know I have to talk about Civil War
and I have to wonder
maybe there won't be a civil war
because that would require more than one
faction and if the left right now is
able to engage in this degree of
terrorism and its terrorism and even Fox
News is like they're just being detained
because they're agitators then there is
no opposition then all they are is well
we have now talked down the violent
extremism of an ideological Fringe
faction to the point where it's a
protest that's acceptance so what
happens well the police won't arrest
these people you've got drag shows for
children adult performers dancing for
kids the cops won't arrest those people
anyway at all it seems like whether you
want to accept it or not they've won
already and so what may be coming is not
going to be a civil war but a culture
revolution in which case we will see
more of this we've got a bunch of
stories in this regard we could talk
about as well California is imposing a
new rule that if movies are not woke
they will lose tax benefits it is being
enshrined in law so anyway now that I've
ranted a little bit I don't know if you
all agree with me but uh what do you
think am I am I off am I have I lost it
no I think the upside of this situation
if you could really call it an upside is
that the people were arrested 35 of
people were arrested 23 have been
charged thus far as four hours ago or
something like that so there has been
response yes captured and on their way
to being indicted perhaps what I think
about the framing is renditioned yes let
them be renditioned
I'm kidding about the auditioning you
have a gathering and then if a gathering
starts gets gets directed they might
turn into a protest it's still a form of
gathering a protest then if the protest
gets violent it becomes a riot it's
still a form of protest and it's still a
gathering and then but it's to call a
riot so you have to defer to the most
violent aspect of the Gathering and call
it that you are correct and then if it's
been two years of an organized group in
this one area and they've shot a police
officer put him in the hospital and they
have guns and explosives and Molotov
cocktails then they recruit more people
under a shared Banner from across the
country and other countries to descend
on a government facility to Fire Bomb
equipment and attack police officers and
forcers of Law and and agents of the
government I think you are well past
riot
yeah this was an attack they attacked
the compound right it's a terror attack
and they were arrested justly sorry Phil
what did you say let's call it an
offensive there you go it was uh it was
aged offensive yeah it was a stage
defensive it's a faction of violent
extremists who are organized
International with allies weapons
explosives using lethal Force to destroy
a government facility we're we're in the
we're in the beginning phases of a
cultural revolution in the United States
similar to the one that happened in
China I think we're at the end of the
beginning phase the beginning phase was
weird wokeness and movies having you
know a plethora of interracial you know
gay sex scenes oh yeah 911 getting us
all to hate each other
I would like to finish what I was saying
because I don't wanna I don't want that
getting cut off what I'm saying is
California enforcing by law now that you
have to have these ethnic quotas and
gender quotas I don't care if a movie is
gonna have you know interracial gay
dating or whatever people can make
whatever movies they want I'm talking
about the enshrining and law of it yeah
I was interested in getting some funding
one time and I was looking up Government
funding and stuff like that for the Arts
and I noticed that there was these
requirements that was your either part
of the LGBT community a person of color
all the whole list you know whatever
that whole list is and you can get some
funding but nowhere in there was
anything that I qualified for like being
a white CIS a straight woman Siz what
does that mean that sounds like a slur
it actually is considered a slur Yeah by
a lot of people but I just found it
interesting too yeah they do yeah
because I've been attacked on you know
social media where they're just like you
CIS your CIS and it's like very like
antagonizing it's it's insulting but I'm
just making that point where like I was
looking for funding and how can I get
out there and make some arts and do do
something and get some government
funding and I I found that there was
nowhere for me to get funding
yeah I completely think that we're in
the middle of a cultural revolution I
think that and unless we have uh
concerted effort by your average person
to push back on these uh these type of
well first of all these activities you
have to have people that are going to
say look we want law enforcement to do
something about this
um and so far I don't think the
population in the U.S has really decided
that they're they're fed up with it and
until the population starts pressuring
their representatives uh you're not
going to see any kind of significant
change and I'm too scared exactly I
don't think that that they're I don't
think I can tell you this man
you know a civil war requires multiple
factions deciding that their ideology is
correct but when you have a passive
faction and an active faction I don't
think you get Civil War you get
Revolution the far left right now has
just laid Siege to a government facility
with people from outside this country
and the media is is protecting it even
Fox News Fox News should outright say
terror attack no question when when the
when the Overton window has shifted to
the point where you can get a band of
people over several years shooting at
cops fire bombing government facilities
and it's called agitators at a
demonstration then you've already
normalized what they're doing to the
point where you accept it this Legend
This This lends credibility to the to
what uh Rusty Rockets was saying on Bill
Marshall that uh MSNBC Fox News they're
all the same ah he's wrong you think
he's wrong he's absolutely wrong
wrestler
Russell Brand's great but I did correct
him earlier on my uh Tim cast News
YouTube channel yeah if you look at the
News Guard rating of MSNBC it says
proceed with caution not credible and
Fox News is deemed generally credible I
don't hate that fox and Fox News like
the okay look foxnews.com factual news
reporting with a conservative tint MSNBC
opinion conspiracy video garbage yeah
Fox News on cable TV mostly
straightforward news all day until you
get to Tucker Hannity and Laura Ingram
and then Tucker is actually pretty good
but a little snooty and snarky people
like him for it MSNBC all day is
conspiracy garbled nonsense so Russell
Brand goes on Bill Maher and says you've
MSNBC is the same thing as Fox News it's
biased nonsense blah blah blah it's like
well he mentions why won't they talk
about Julian Assange and Snowden and
it's like Tucker Carlson does so Fox
News is not in that camp you've got the
populists and you've got the cultists
and MSNBC is the cult conspiracy
Channel's been wrong basically about
everything yeah I think that there he
was kind of extending an olive branch by
saying hey both sides have issues guys
but the truth is the liberal economic
order is utilizing that media
organization whether it's MSNBC or CNN I
don't know how they are owned they're
owned by similar structures or whatever
I mean he's always been
anti-establishment so I see why he's
saying that he's always been kind of
against all that but I feel like he's
starting to kind of see the light a
little bit more on the right more than
he used to in the past well when I went
on Russell's show the first time they
invited me I was kind of like it's gonna
be an ambush they think they're gonna
like get me with something but that was
a good conversation Russell's he's a
smart dude I think he's and he's genuine
absolutely yeah and I I he had me on his
show again recently I think he's
fantastic I just think there there are
many people who are who are late to the
party and I don't mean that
disrespectfully exactly I'm glad they
made it to the party at all hope they
brought some pizza or wings or something
but don't come empty-handed Russell is
bringing a horde of followers and people
who believe in him and trust him he's
he's been a populist on the left for for
a long time calling up calling out the
machine he's now seeing exactly how
broken things are he's calling it out as
it needs to be but
I don't think he watches Fox News I
think he's still of that world where Fox
is bad but now he realizes MSNBC is bad
and so he's like hey wait a minute
that's exactly if you're on the left and
you hear Fox News Fox News Fox News is
what they do then you watch MSNBC you go
hey wait a minute that's exactly what
Fox News is doing ah it's exactly what
they told you Fox News is doing and what
they used to do they warmongered hard in
2008-7-6 uh for the Iraq afghanistans I
mean that was the the right the the war
Monger uh they called him neocons at the
time and it was like this this yeah the
Republican Party by the The Cheney
Dynasty and George Bush Jr you know
they're a huge War I mean and seeing uh
Fox parrot at that really really they
were really disingenuous in those years
in in let's let's uh uh pull up this
tweet from Andy no we have this uh this
is shocking a shocking Revelation Andy
no initially reported this morning
before we got new information at least
23 stop cop cities suspects were
arrested in Atlanta on suspicion of
domestic Terror over the violent Ambush
on police almost all are from out of
state one of the terror suspects is a
Southern Poverty Law Center staff
attorney
and another is a Canadian academic story
to come this is crazy the splc has
responded by admitting that their guy
was there this is shocking you'd think
they want to deny and be like nope nope
no oh nope they outright said it law
enforcement detained at least 35
demonstrators in Atlanta including an
splc employee who was arrested while
acting and identifying as a legal
Observer on behalf of nlg news I would
just like to point something out
if uh you're a lawyer and uh you're with
a bunch of people who just who have said
to rob a bank and you go into the bank
with them and you're dressed like them
I'm sorry you're an accomplice this is
not a protest the legal observers
typically go to demonstrations or people
are marching down the street and they
watch and then when the cops Act a Fool
they say we saw that
this was a group of terrorists
ransacking breaking onto private onto
Government property and burning it to
the ground and then what an splc
employee decided to join them just to
watch yeah you're not exempt from
breaking into a government facility
because you're an attorney for a
non-profit so all they've done thus far
is admit he was actually there they say
it's part of a months-long escalation of
police tactics blah blah blah blah but
the fact that a terror a terrorist cell
and a national chapter anti-fundance
International Associates have support
from the national lawyers Guild in the
Southern Poverty Law Center shows you
just how far gone we are and how close
we are to a legitimate culture
Revolution and I'm sure the left is very
excited about it of course they are I
mean they've been it's something that
has been in the works for a lot of years
this is not new this started I I would
say that the foundation was laid in the
80s with Paolo Ferrari's influence in
schools and then with the influence of
Paolo Ferrari in the schools of
Education in the 90s start pumping out
these kids from the humanities
departments that all believe that
essentially socialism is the way I think
it goes even farther than that what was
the Long March since in the institutions
yeah the 60s that was you started a
creep in right was it the the term was
coined by Antonio Ramsey who was a like
McCarthyism he wrote in the 20s but that
wow really yeah Antonio Graham she wrote
from an Italian prison in the 20s and
he's the one that's came up with the
idea that you had to go through the
institutions and change the culture and
they did and that's exactly what they
did well Mao did it and he proved that
it works and now it's being done here
there's a couple ideas pertaining to the
Long March to through the institutions
and uh Yuri besmanov of course most
people who watch the show are familiar
with talk about the demoralization and
the subversion of the United States this
was of course during the Cold War and so
one of the scariest theories is the
Soviet zombie takedown of the United
States and that idea is the Soviets
implanted these ideas into the United
States to basically plant seeds that
would eventually destroy and uproot this
country
we may be experiencing that but the
Soviet Union no longer exists so this is
like it's it's it's kind of creepy it's
like almost perfect for a movie where
like a spaceship crew comes across it'll
actually there's like a Star Trek
episode about this they come to a planet
and there's a doomsday weapon armed
ready to go because of a war that was
going on the Soviet Union like the ghost
of the Soviet Union is in America now
it's right yeah it's corrupt the Soviet
the Soviet exists it's just not unified
as as they were we were at War they
implanted a poison in the U.S were
destroyed themselves but that poison
remained and the attack was terminal
this is a double knockout and I mean
another thing about the institutions and
the universities in particular was the
um critical race Theory which you know
we know about that now it's actually
kind of crazy because I remember looking
this up back in 2016 and it was all this
information about how it got its roots
also with the Soviet stuff because they
were wanted to have a way of like
breaking down what the family unit and
and all those things so that they can be
dependent on the state and what have you
but they got its way into Columbia
University with the Frankfurt School or
whatever I found all this information
about it and I was like researching it
if you look that up now today it says
right-wing conspiracy theory yep like
there's no actual information documents
documents about it and I'm like where
did it go it used to be on the wild wild
west of the internet I found it all the
documents not anymore there was like a
big moment when Wikipedia I think they
went in and started changing all the
information on the Frankfurt School
calling it a conspiracy theory but it
existed no and that's the academic name
yeah yeah came from Columbia University
Herbert Marcus and and and the scholars
that were that were involved in there
and I mean right now we live in the
logic of Herbert Marquis that's why we
don't have uh the the federal government
going after the left the way they go
after the right the left is apologized
for is made excuses for is allowed to
behave in in violent ways in ways that
are completely unacceptable for people
on the right and according to Mark
Hughes he believes that even the ideas
that would come from the right must be
suppressed let me let me blow your mind
everybody who's listening I have this
article from Fox 5 Atlanta Georgia
Trooper stable after being shot
protester killed near controversial cop
City police facility site it's from
January 18 2023 a police officer gets
shot
they then opened fire on the assailants
killing one of the terrorists how do you
think the guardian wrote about it here
you go the victim assassinated in Cold
Blood activist killed protesting
Georgia's cop City killing of Manuel
Esteban Perez Tehran who opposed
training facilities unprecedented in
history of environmental activism I'd
say you want to know what else is
unprecedented is probably this passage
in their own story officials say Manuel
shot first at a State Trooper without
quote without warning and an officer or
officers returned fire but they have
produced no evidence for the claim
the trooper was described as stable and
in the hospital Thursday there's no
evidence except for the cop in the
hospital
so uh what and that where's their foot
in a level three the footnote was added
on 24 between the final editing and
publication the gbi released information
including a photograph of a handgun and
the agency said was in Manuel turan's
position the gbil said forensic analysis
confirmed the projectile recover from
the trooper's wound matched this handgun
but there's no evidence see footnote not
only did they have evidence a cop was in
the hospital and they still wrote what
they have produced no evidence for the
claim the trooper was described as
stable in the hospital
so did the bullet fall from the sky what
did did someone in a plane Drop just the
bullet with you know just and it landed
on the cop and he went oh how did that
happen I don't even think a bullet
falling at terminal velocity would be
able to penetrate a human body
it's gross I'm impressed with the with
the media so this is the point when our
institutions are actively defending
terrorism and the subversion of this
country kind of feels like you already
lost but I know I'll tell you the cops
man they played it right this time they
they killed no one they arrested
Thursday they killed the guy oh right
this last time they were able to because
it would have been like three dead in
clash with police or three dead
protesters innocent protesters killed
some you know really manipulative story
they didn't kill anybody they arrested
35 people they charged 23 so far I think
they're doing it right what do you guys
think is worse is it worse if the police
do their job and a protester dies when
the police are trying to you know stop
the violence or trying to detain people
or whatever or is it better for some
people in like like proud boys or
whatever to get fed up and decide
they're going to go encounter protest
and actually get into a fight with him
and and have someone die in that
situation obviously neither are good but
which one's going to have the worst
repercussions on the for society I think
if a group going and fighting with the
cops and getting a kill is worse for
society because it's going to provoke
more if there's there's no there's the I
guess you can look at it this way my
view is if there is no opposing faction
then you get a Communist Revolution and
we know where that goes if there's an
opposing faction you get a Civil War and
we know where that goes and neither of
which is good not neither is better than
the other I suppose you could argue that
following a civil war if the right
faction wins but basically every single
time we we see a civil war resolve
there's some nightmarish thing that
occurs afterwards for decades I'm still
of the opinion that if we do have a
civil war that that it's going to have
reverberations around the world I don't
know what would happen but there it's
not like we don't get to have the United
States does not have a civil war and
then the rest of the world doesn't react
that's true I want to pull up this image
real quick just so I can people can get
to get to educate I'll get you get you
educated a little bit I'm not going to
pretend to be a scholar on the Spanish
Civil War I just want to use this map to
point out right now there's a lot of
people talking about National divorce
and Civil War and they're very skeptical
they're saying things like we can't have
it we shouldn't have it well I'm not
here to say we should or should anything
like well actually we shouldn't for sure
but they show this map of the US and
they show cities and it's the Democrat
versus Republican voting base and
they're like oh yeah like we could have
a civil war now and they show a map of
the U.S and it's like these people don't
realize that even back in the day there
was an urban versus rural divide and
they seemed to think today that there
can't be a civil war because while
California is blue but you know the
other states in the in the Midwest and
south are red and that separates it blah
blah blah this is a map of the Spanish
Civil War territories from 1936 to 1939
as that and at and as you can see it
doesn't necessarily make a whole lot of
sense logistically it's not like half
the Country Split there's some in 1938
you had the Republican control in two
different bifurcated areas
in this 1936 they controlled the north
but not just directly below them to
Madrid it didn't quite make sense the
territories that were controlled if
there was a real Civil War in this
country it would not be State against
State it's going to be like every other
civil war throughout history where
extremist factions seized control of
certain areas that's it I think looking
at this map of Spain that there's a
mountain range they're north of like in
the Northeast that may be a divider and
the reason why it's split I don't really
know the history of the Spanish Civil
War to be honest um there are Geographic
you know things that'll be like you know
we'll have a divisions
and you can look at Syria as well and in
real Civil Wars basically what happens
is in an area with a high density of one
political faction they seize control but
that might mean they only control a city
and they don't control the surrounding
areas and they might not have any
control within 100 miles outside the
city at all
I think people don't really they're
underestimating uh the states the blue
States because I'm from New York and
just like you were saying California
there's like more rural areas of
California and New York that people
don't realize they're they're pretty red
if you look at the map also the voting
map of it it's pretty red it's just New
York City Buffalo and that's why they're
all cities and that's why what would
likely happen in a real Civil War is
that the New York Metro would be
controlled by one faction and the rural
areas by others the and then we have
guns too well the problem for a pla the
problem for these cities is that they
they need to get resources somehow and
so what would likely happen in my
opinion is that New York with its some
30 000 or so police officers the New
York Metro probably has substantially
more than that and they would easily
recruit surrounding suburbs and extended
beyond the metro into places like
Connecticut which is only a couple hours
drive they would come to Upstate New
York where it's debt it's sparsely
populated and just take what they want
it's the end of story so well they don't
have the guns in the city but the
upstaters have the guns except the New
York City Police Department has better
guns substantially better guns and a lot
of them and then you've also got do you
think that they're working for someone
or are they going on behalf of
themselves
they will work for the state because the
state's home absolutely they're gonna
say you want food and they're gonna say
yes I do they say okay they'll fight for
their Community probably a lot of times
they have to bring in federal troops to
fight the locals because right the
problem is these cops aren't from there
the cops don't live around there they
may be in the extended area but
typically what happens is the military
comes to you or the government and they
say we're going to make sure you have
food right now it's really uncertain I
know nobody wants to cut no nobody wants
conflict nobody wants to fight but trust
us we're here to help everybody and stop
the crazy people and we're going to make
sure your family has food I tell you
this these guys like in every country
we've ever seen with conflict they will
I'll keep it family friendly they will
hug the government officers offering
them food if it meant they have some we
see this everywhere you look at
Venezuela the Venezuelan National Guard
are willing to shoot college students
because they're guaranteed food at a
time of Crisis and starvation dude if
there was real chaos people would do
pretty much anything to survive yeah
anything
and they're going to come to you and say
we will destroy you first the first
thing will say look if you're if you're
in these areas you most likely agree
already they don't need to convince you
do anything they're going to be like the
crazy Trump conspiracy theorists who
think lizard people control the world
are coming we need you to stop them and
the people are going to believe it
they're going to turn on CNN and CNN's
going to tell them what to do and
they're going to say okay look if you
you tell me you don't believe me
take a look at Texas where you've got
adult entertainers dancing for babies
and children with a big neon sign saying
it's not going to lick itself and the
cops going uh listen I can't get
involved here
they're not they're not going to defy
these factions even if the law is on
their side they will not do it they will
do what they're told as per the cult and
New York cops will definitely do it
that's why we have an armed populace but
that means you will get a divide between
urban and rural so the question is just
because the people outside the cities
are armed doesn't mean they're organized
in which case you get a culture
Revolution the government gets taken
over by one faction and immediately
issues sweeping reforms and starts let's
just say removing those dissidents yeah
that's what's happened every time in
history throughout eons of of what we
know of revolution is that swiftly the
government solidifies power and then
takes control of the Crackdown but we're
in a new time with massive amounts of
decentralized information transfer we
can use shortwave radio people are armed
to the teeth at an individual level
house by house it's not it's a very
different experiment the United States
local governance is the is the is like
the central core of the of the country
so like it would be tough to strip the
the key would be to control the airwaves
and manipulate information I think if
you could do that you could get people
force people to keep using your your
money then you will control the the
counter I think I think the issue is
that's what they've been trying to do
clearly
and it's not working because you can't
there's a crypto you just can't it's
like a difference the The Establishment
has has lost control of the narrative
machine but it doesn't mean that some
horrible thing can't emerge it's just
maybe it wouldn't be the establishment
it may be to be some crazy cult or some
some NFL sports team we have a crazy
cult in charge look what they're trying
to do with disinformation they're trying
to suspend censor they're trying to get
laws passed so they can control the flow
of information to control your mind and
they are struggling with it and as much
as I would say
you know the far left extremism is being
placated or accepted the information War
rages on with shows like this the back
in the 70s when Nixon went to China the
general idea was if we expose China to
markets and to uh we welcome them into
the the global community and we expose
them to markets they will become more
like us and the opposite has happened
the United States because of the the
control that China has over their
population that
was an attractive
situation to politicians and people that
you know us that would would look for
power and so what happened was they saw
the situation in China and they they've
decided that they want that type of
control for the United States and
honestly for the rest of the world when
you start talking about wef and and
things like that if you look at the
wdwef's
website there's all kinds of references
to Global governance Global governance
if they weren't looking to have a
globalized government they wouldn't be
talking about global governance and they
wouldn't be having these these meetings
at Davos with the U.S all the movers and
shakers from the U.N this is a move to
actually make a global communist state
essentially why do you think that anyone
in the United States would want that for
the United States I don't think that
there are very many people that want it
there is an extremist group an extremist
Fringe of the left that do believe that
Global communism is the future and
that's the way forward uh the
dissolution of Nations totally this is
global communism no what that's the only
way that it's true government or why
true communism sorry why the Viet Cong
why the North Koreans why the the
Chinese why the
why in Russia is why central planning at
all why why did it happen any point in
any of these countries did this emerge
it seems like it always starts off with
someone that thinks it would be better
if we all work together so we're gonna
make a small Council and make sure that
we all work together and then the
council gets power and they're like
there's no way we can make that work
let's just take what we got you I think
it's more so what you're seeing is like
mold or cancer
these people these far left extremists
who are firebombing this this facility
they have no solutions to anything they
are proposing literally nothing when
Greta tunberg was asked what do you
propose we do said it's not my job to
give you answers well then what are you
doing
you all you're doing is burning things
down not building anything that's
exactly right the whole project of the
left is they believe that the perfected
Society is exists and the way to find it
is to pull apart Society you tear things
down and the more you pull away the more
it exposes the existing perfected
Society that's these that's the attempt
that's where critical theory comes into
play is the whole concept and you know
these universities was how do we
criticize each aspect of society and
culture and that's the whole game and
that's what you notice that left does
everything is a critique everything's a
critique and to break it down what I
find though is that in this Society the
only reason we're able to critique it
with such accuracy is because it's a
free society and if we start clamping
down we'll no longer be able to critique
the problem
and so the critique itself is we we must
leave open yeah Society for critique at
all times the reason that Chernobyl
melted down is because people were
afraid to say hey this is bad and this
is this is going on there's mistakes
it's because people were afraid to speak
honestly and openly so you're 100 right
you guys know how uh The Simpsons
basically predicts everything yeah I'm
gonna play this video clip real quick
can we do I have the audio turned on
yeah
there we go let's get it
let's come back to haunt him good Homer
Simpson be a communist his father spoke
out on his behalf my Homer is not a
communist he may be a liar a Pig
a communist but he is not a porn star
Joe Biden
it's over there
oh it's coming Soviet Union will be
placed
at the Soviet Union I thought you guys
broke up yes that's what we wanted you
to think
[Music]
she is
oh must crash capitalism that was worth
a minute and 10 seconds so basically
communism fed off of the Soviet Union
until it killed it and then it
transferred over to China and now it's
sucking the brain of China and it's
trying to get into the United States is
it trying to kill China like split it up
into a bunch of what hyper capitalist
States and just be gone with it that was
very backwards well like you're saying
like the Soviet Union's like haha we
never really left like well the
Communist aspect of it never really left
the world it just moved from country to
Country just like the war machine moved
from the Republican party to the
Democrat Party communism's finding a
home in different superpowers or has
been over the last hundred years but to
the left even know how the communism in
the Soviet Union was like they were not
pro LGBT or any of that stuff these are
the these vary against that yeah and
these uh and Che Guevara you know that
guy was was a bigot but these these
leftists who are like oh communism
they'd be the people who'd be breaking
Rock first
they're the ones who get arrested locked
up and then go break rocks to figure out
what hard work is like they're useful
idiots no offense I'm not calling you
personally an idiot no like people that
are willing to like push the agenda
without realizing what it means these
people these antiva types they don't
work they run around LARPing and setting
fires they don't have jobs that's why
the Idle Hands the Devil's Playground
you put these people in a construction
site and give them actual jobs and a
purpose and a goal and they're not
burning down cities
satisfied people don't Revolt happy
people don't start engaging
revolutionary activities if you have a
society that is essentially getting
along you don't I I almost I somewhat
disagree they're purposeless
so they want they want for very little
so they create the wants
because people want to strive for
something but if you're food shelter I
mean look back in the day people had to
work you didn't have time for evolution
you're telling the fields man you gotta
Winter's coming but now that Americans
are morbidly obese and playing video
games all day they're listless and bored
and they need to create a purpose and
they found one yeah it's the purpose
it's that's where the cult-like
mentality comes into play too because
like it gives them something a sense of
something bigger like most people have
religion or some sort of purpose family
or something and that's where the
breaking down of the family unit or
religion or all that it like creates
purpose for their agenda that that's
it's a religion to them you've had
experience with antifa and their
antagonism towards individuals yourself
right yeah I have
um I didn't even know I didn't even know
what antifa was
um but then they wrote an article in
2016 where it was like New York City
Nazis or something and I was like what's
this and they like doxed where I work my
hometown and like my associations and
everything and they're just like these
are New York City Nazis and I'm like I
thought it was like funny at first
because this is a joke this is crazy and
then I found out that there was this
thing called antifa and yeah they I I
had to live in fear of like my address I
mean you know what that's like you know
getting docked or
um people showing up randomly or
something and I'm just like a girl
living in Brooklyn and I'm like oh my
God what is their purpose in this like
what is the point of them posting my
address and saying she's a Nazi
go-getter guys like that's dangerous was
it because the stuff you posted online
yeah it was because at the time I was
you know the whole my whole world was
left us people and and work and all that
and I didn't know anyone else that had
the same mindset that I had the same
beliefs that I had so I would look to
the internet and and see stuff and I
found Gavin McGinnis and he's in New
York City compound Studio
so then I started going on his show and
getting a little bit more involved and
so my association with Gavin during the
beginning of like the proud boy era and
everything is why they targeted me and I
became like part of that
um what is called article and so it was
really scary and then we see what
happened with the proud boys you know it
became this drinking club that was just
fun and silly goofy thing in New York
City and I was like what are you guys
talking about this is just you know
drinking Club for Men and then it turned
into they're being arrested for
fighting fighting with antifa outside of
the Republican Club what is antifa doing
there and somehow proud boys are the bad
guys and they're in jail for guys how
many years yeah take a look at the the
mistake made by the proud voice when the
police came the proud boys went hello
officer let me tell you everything an
antifa ran away yeah and now none of the
antifa guys are in jail and the proud
boys are
it's it's just incredible Hatton that
you were talking about that earlier too
about the how they demonize like the
certain group and that's exactly what
they did and in the beginning my agent
the theater that I worked at none of
these people understood what was going
on they were just like what this weird
politics fight like whatever and they
kept booking me but then it turned into
now even like your mom will know what
proud boys is like the presidential
debates are talking about the proud boys
and if you're Associated to that you are
like people want to go oh we can't book
her like even if they agree with you or
sympathetic with you your Association
and they did that to the proud boys
which is they put this Association
that's bad onto them and it's just
mind-boggling how they did it I don't
even know how they did it just uh let's
see they like how did this happen it's
this simple there's one faction fighting
so for instance we tried booking a show
at a theater in Pitman New Jersey antifa
threatened to burn the theater her down
so the theater canceled and said sue us
the damage we incur from a canceled
contract is less and the damage to a
burned down theater
that's how it works I think it's what we
really should be doing is blaming the
behaviors themselves that people are
doing and not the people not the groups
not the affiliations but the behavior
and it it doesn't always sit well with
people because they're like yo if you
identify with the Nazi party I'm
supposed to have an issue with that but
if you have a conversation with someone
who identifies as a Nazi and it's the
most loving conversation let the
conversation stand on its own don't
don't judge the person based on what you
think it means to have that label
slapped on their chest that's key and
that's important for us moving forward
because a lot of these kids drag shows
where like underage kids are being
sexualized or or cut up or whatever in
the future when that stuff's made
illegal there's going to be a desire to
go persecute those people that did that
stuff and it's no if it's not happening
now it's not happening anymore yeah wait
wait wait are you saying not to
prosecute people who are committing
crimes well in the future when it
becomes illegal and if they're not doing
it anymore don't go back and be like
what you did eight years ago is now
illegal so you're going to talk right
right yeah that's cancer culture
problem is it's already illegal so they
should be arrested for the laws of the
books now if it is illegal yeah yeah
yeah it is we've gone over it enticement
of a minor I mean come on you can't have
an adult man in a thong thrust into the
face of a child like those those laws
are on the books imagine if somebody
walked up to a grade school and started
doing those dances in front of all those
kids at recess so to clarify and to
continue on don't blame all trans people
for what some trans people have done or
don't blame all people in drag but drag
queens are not trans people yeah and
don't so don't blame the groups of these
people based on what some behaviors that
have transpired that's that's key that's
part of if you want to exonerate the
proud boys for instance it's that kind
of mentality yeah we still can't be
wrong sometimes they behave a certain
way I mean I didn't necessarily agree
with the January 6th thing I thought it
was stupid like what are we doing guys
but is it right to say that it's an
Insurrection and that these this was
like so terrible no that's stupid like
let's uh let's jump to the story from
the Daily Mail because we all care so
much about Joe Rogan's opinion bleeding
heart liberal Joe Rogan says he'd vote
for Trump before Biden because he's
mentally gone and Americans now have to
rely on his on his side show of
diversity Administration he was talking
to Russell Brand
he basically said that
now look Russell Brand and Joe Rogan are
very similar kind of guys liberal-ish
comedians ones you know he's a British
guy one's an american guy and here they
are talking to each other and Rogan's at
the point now where he said in the past
he wouldn't vote for Biden but he
wouldn't he didn't vote for Trump now
he's saying he'd vote for Trump before
Biden which is you know Joe's moving
over a little bit see here's what I
think
you got a lot of liberals who know in
their heart of hearts Trump is the right
answer albeit an imperfect one but you
definitely can't support Biden
and they don't want to say it because
they're scared so they'll they'll
they'll play a middle of the road kind
of game and act like they're some
Centrist or whatever or they're
disaffected but they won't just come out
and say the truth
so we see this a lot of these
politically homeless people on Twitter
well where they will still promote and
obviously fake story smearing Trump just
to try and be like Oh and to that point
Russell Brand saying MSNBC and Fox News
are just as bad any honest assessment of
the facts would show you that Fox News
while not perfect is substantially more
factual than MSNBC even News Guard
thinks so and that's an establishment
news rating agency but you still get
these people
who are going to be like oh you know I
wouldn't vote for Trump I'm not going to
do it I don't know I wouldn't be
surprised to find out that Rogan
actually did vote for Trump now if he
says he didn't I believe him but if if
he came out and said you know actually I
did vote for him I'd be like oh that
didn't surprise me at all but the fact
that he's saying it now I think we're
going to start seeing more of a pushback
there's this viral video of this woman
being like let me tell you about frog
and frog self pronouns and how to use
them and then a guy goes that's it I'm a
republican he sucks down and he's like
frog self the Frog gender and so this
guy's like I'm a republican you got me
I'm out I'm vote Republican because I'm
not going to call the person a frog it
ain't happening when you're offered
Donald Trump or frog self
that's that's really what we're being
given we're being given Donald Trump
who's kind of crazy or completely
detached from reality it's like a form
of radicalization but in the reverse
sense like I hate that thing so radical
move uh so she well this is what the
left Dude too and my husband talks about
this um and he wrote a book about it
because he had experience in the far
right and
um
he talks about and I feel like it was
starting to happen to me when I got
doxed by antifa and all that but they
push people to be more Radical by acting
the way that they are you know like
they do these things to people they're
saying these frogs sell things or
whatever and it pushes people like all
the way to the other end
the response the reason that well the
response to Communism is almost always
fascism
right people get sick and tired of the
complete Insanity and so then they're
just like well who's gonna make things
normal and that's what that's what
Hitler did in in the uh or the or the
argument that the Nazis made not what
Hitler did the argument that the Nazis
made to get elected or when they were
trying to get elected was we will
restore order we all the fighting in the
streets will stop because there was so
much agitation from antifa the
Communists in why the Weimar Republic
and the response from the population is
we're fed up with this Insanity so we
want someone that's going to give us Law
and Order and it's always and it pushes
to an extreme and I felt that way when
when they did all that they did to me
ruined my career doxed me like did all
the stuff just destroyed my life it
almost made me want to just go
completely the other end when they're
calling me a Nazi you know but you have
to like control that and and to not kind
of buy into that but it's also dangerous
when they're calling people like Tucker
Carlson or regular normal people natsus
that's also going to push people to like
the far end like okay well I guess we're
all Nazis then so what's a better
Victory to engage in fascist Crackdown
law order or just mockery let okay so
there's more than two choices
using mockery no well Tim's right
mockery mockery is a way to fight them
but the the the ideology or or not the
ideology but the political path that the
United States needs to get Beyond is a
liberal path now there's going to be
people that are going to say we can't
you know liberalism can't take uh can't
take authoritarian impulses because
liberalism is innately uh naive I guess
is what a lot of people would say you
you're you're your impulse is to listen
to the argument from the from the
original classical liberal yeah I don't
and I don't believe as a classical
liberal solution yeah so like Tim says
like there's some people that don't
believe it because they don't believe
that that voting will will work they
don't believe that because of
intimidation and stuff like that and I
get it but I think that the options are
authoritarianism or liberalism so you
get right authoritarium
I mean it's not authoritarianism versus
libertarianism libertarianism is not
binary it's it is a gradient so you can
be the moderately authoritarian or
moderately libertarian you can be Center
in between and I think the issue is the
people who are classically liberal have
traditionally been in a sort of it's I
would say their their Centrist
libertarian types that are not all the
way down at the bottom towards Anarchy
but they're not quite conservative
they're not leftist or anything and
these people allow authoritarians to do
whatever they want which means you need
a more I don't know service guarantee
citizenship kind of approach where you
get your constitutional rights I mean
Starship Trooper style service guarantee
citizenship if you're not a member of
the community who's contributing you
don't vote on things that solves the
problem very very quickly now the
problem however is it could also
exacerbate the problem very quickly
which is why some have proposed it
because if those institutions get
captured who gets LED in to perform
Services who gets a to vote it could it
could isolate very very quickly the
simple answer is you still need a strong
moral foundation and you need I guess
what you would call cultural tradition
in which the people that you agree with
come together periodically organize
together speak to one another have
something that bonds them together and
they reject outside of it and that needs
to be the dominant umbrella so when I
say mockery what I mean to say is Jimmy
Kimmel
this is what he does he goes on TV and
Aaron and takes a clip of Aaron Rodgers
saying I'm looking forward to seeing if
the Epstein list list gets released him
that gets released and then Jimmy Kimmel
laughs at him and calls him a tin foil
hat guy what he's talking about a news
story about I've seen Client List I mean
Elaine Maxwell's in jail this stuff's
happening she got convicted how is that
tinfoil hat what he's doing is he's
trying to create the sphere of influence
to say this is what you must be if you
want to be safe in our society
the right needs control of those
institutions it's not going to be this
let us come together and have a debate
on stage and discuss the merits of your
uh critical race Theory it's going to be
no we we despise you you're a moral
crackpot cultists and we're going to
make fun of you and we are going to
command the institutions and then we're
going to say you are not welcome to
speak here but the good the liberal
tactic would be to get in with Jimmy so
that he trusts you and then mock make a
mockery of him in public on his own show
to show why he's wrong and then get all
his followers to follow you instead
that's not a liberal tactic that would
be like a peaceful like joke
approach as a speech and debate yeah the
subversive get into his show and then
undermine him is actually not that's the
point of debate is you get in contact
with someone and then you undermine them
in the process no see the issue is you
have sophists and you have uh liberals
and the Liberals are saying sit down
with me good surf or I might have a
conversation to change your mind and
they say oh here's an opportunity to lie
and twist the facts and take videos out
of context to recruit more people to my
cult yep and liberals keep going I can't
figure out why I'm losing imagine
sitting down in a game of Monopoly and
just letting your your friend be like no
you don't got to pay rent this time I
get it you're hurting your friend goes I
just don't have any money I can't pay
you I'm gonna lose if you make me pay
this time okay and then he's got a huge
wad of cash into the table and he's
buying up properties left and right
that's basically what it is I think it
would be more like you infiltrate into
the network somehow get your own show
and then start subliminally putting in
those jokes of your own or whatever
instead of just like getting on Jimmy
Kimmel and converting those like you
need to get into the institution like
get into the networks get into the
universities get and slowly do what they
did and start changing Minds like a
little bit at a time not everyone has to
be like extreme championing like a cause
get in there slowly yeah and once you
get in the institution starts to change
you and you have to remain steadfast not
because Jon Stewart it's kind of like
that he's sort of able to see the Wuhan
through it all but he's still being
affected and transformed by the
institution being a part of it you say
John Stewart Stewart yeah well I mean
he's like a super Lefty yeah but he's
still able to see like truth really from
time I mean he called out the Wuhan
really virus coming out of Wuhan pretty
clearly earlier on Colbert he deserves
nothing yeah but I mean he's he's also
he made a show crapping on white people
like he is entrenched he stepped out of
line because he's an old fogy who did
not know what that what the cult wanted
and so he goes on TV thinking he was
being himself and then quickly went uh
oh did I say the wrong thing they're
calling me racist now and then he does a
show called something about like the
problem with white people
yeah I just saw him get a clip with
somebody and he was on his own show
dismissed real demeaning about it and
also I was about not letting kids go to
drag shows and he was like what's the
point of that anyway what's the real
deal gun violence let's talk about gun
violence you're like dude because it's
sexualizing children the whole thing the
whole thing was a mess it was it was if
you watched the the whole thing the guy
that he was interviewing almost said
almost nothing and it was all edited so
that way John basically Jon Stewart used
the guy just to do all these off of I
think Sullivan I guess he has his name I
think never do digital interviews man
Sullivan did a digital interview I I
think that's oh they were face to face
and the one I was I'm thinking about it
might be Bill Maher or whatever you do
these digital shows and then you're cut
out from the room and they usually use
you as a prop that's why I don't do
digital here I think John's an example
of someone that infiltrated the liberal
media to change it I know he was
extremely politically active wanting to
get his views across I don't know if
he's necessarily top tier intellect you
know know of our time but he's also been
transformed by that process that's
that's one of the downsides Jon Stewart
spent 20 years making well maybe not 20
years however long he was on uh uh The
Daily Show we spent the entire time that
he was on The Daily Show making any
Republican or repo or conservative idea
completely radioactive well to be fair
though he defended James O'Keefe several
times did he no it wasn't good several
times and he uh gave and he was honest
in what uh James O'Keefe had uncovered
with Acorn and the acorn thing that's
right and he was like how how did
journalists miss this story how is up to
this guy and he shows a young James
wearing the the pimp out for whatever
there's still the damage that he's done
by making conservative ideas radioactive
has been has been far worse than than
antifa honestly we've got big breaking
news I got this clip just popped it up
on Twitter
January 6 video from Tucker Carlson
shows the police assisting the Q Shaman
as he walks around the Capitol Building
no joke let's play the video they helped
him they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
locked doors for him we counted at least
nine officers who were within touching
distance of unarmed Jacob chansley not
one of them even tried to slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6th the India and there it is
right there I mean Tucker is Hansley
they helped obviously got way more to
add to this but there's the video right
there the police escorting him through
the building and finding an open
entrance to get him in
to get him into the chambers
I don't think that's considered
entrapment because he was already on the
premises not when the police are on
camera Fanning people in and opening the
outside doors to let people so we see
corroborative evidence that they let
other people into the building and then
negative evidence that they toured
what's his name again I want to call him
by his real Hensley Jason Chancellor is
that what it is chansley is that what he
said let's play um yeah acted as his
tour guides and Kim chansley they helped
him Jacob they acted as his tour guides
here's video of chansley in the Senate
chamber Capitol police officers take him
to multiple entrances and even try to
open locked doors for him that's amazing
it's Jake Angeli born Jacob Anthony
Angeli chansley uh the police escorted
him through the building I think that's
absolutely exonerates this guy he was he
was being led around by cops I mean this
is why the Democrats would not release
the footage and this is why I have been
saying Ian the Democrats are evil I
don't even I don't want to put on a
political party there are very evil
people doing things right now I don't
want to mask it with a political party
because there's a lot of good Democrats
too I will name Democrats or even name
one name a good Democrat my mom I think
that I'm talking about the political
officers I'm talking about the
politicians who are sitting on the j6
committee who are withholding evidence
that would exonerate a man who he's been
locked up ever since hasn't he yeah I
think so so name name for me a good
sitting Democrat Bernie Sanders he's not
a Democrat he's independent
and besides he came out in favor of War
but Bernie he's a good guy
um nobody's perfect I mean I can
scarcely name a an honest Republican are
you sure I didn't know Bernie was
independent sorry about that Thomas
Massey
I could give maybe rokana a a nod I
don't know a lot of them though I don't
know I don't know many of them at all
aoc's being implicated in uh ethics
investigation because she got all this
free stuff Conde Nast paid for her her
uh her limo or whatever her ride to the
Met Gala she that that's look we had
Matt Gates come into the studio and
we've got a fine selection of bourbon
and I said uh Congressman Gates please
help yourself to anything you might
partake a drink you may partake and uh
he said that's too expensive I can't
accept that for the for the Pappy stuff
and I was a bottom shelf five dollar
garbage if you want to have some whiskey
it's got to be under a certain price and
I was like oh no no yeah whatever I
don't I don't know do just make sure you
do it right he's like yeah no problem
AOC received hundreds if not thousands
of dollars these people I'm sorry they
are evil anything January sorry the
January 6 committee was sitting on a ex
evidence that would exonerate this man
and they lied about it for power and
Raskin
lied about me
when he played a video and and this was
a big mistake on the part of the
Democrats because it red pilled a lot of
yeah including my mother exactly because
I was reading a Fox News article where
Trump says we're going to protest it's
going to be wild and it's like Fox news
reporting Donald Trump says it's going
to be a while I was like well you know
it might be because Trump supporters are
really angry he plays it out of context
and then what I'm hearing from my
friends is like what you just said
people being like what
Tim Poole's not calling for anything now
that's crazy these people are evil yeah
they definitely put things out of
context to purposely ruin lives and they
did the same thing the media did it with
me when I worked at the Daily Caller I
was in a video with Ajit Pai who's the
head of the FCC at the time and they
were like repealing that neutrality
and I was just in a video like in the
background dancing along to some silly
meme video that they were making with
him and the media left leftist media
wanted to destroy him because this net
neutrality thing which I still don't
even understand what was going on with
it
but they pinpointed me and said hmm
what's what's her deal and they found
like a silly YouTube video that I made
about like pizzagate but it was really
just like me talking about my experience
on the Deep Web and like knowing that
this cheese pizza code actually is a
real code I did not talk about common
ping pong I did not talk about anything
that was like
bad about this conspiracy theory thing
but they went around Joy read on MSNBC
mentioned me by name every single outlet
was mentioning me and lying flat out
lying saying that I promoted highly
promoted the Comet Ping Pong conspiracy
theory which I never did just because
you knew that CP meant was always
they knew that no one would actually
look at my video they knew that no one
would do that they just read the article
and then I was getting a bunch of
messages and everybody hating me and it
was just like now my reputation is I'm a
piece of Gator when I'm like I never did
that I think I never promoted this like
conspiracy theory I was just talking
about the Deep Web the cheese pizza is
actually not even that deep that's just
on that's on 4chan on on the B board
people have been arrested for putting
cheese pizza code out there for actual
travel there's a rest you can look up
articles about it but they they don't
care they lie they did it on purpose and
it what did it do they wanted to ruin
Ajit Pai for this you know political
reason but really it ruins this girl's
me reputation for what that's all they
they care about they don't care about me
as a person or good doing good the
Democrats only have one thing to
campaign on Donald Trump is a Nazi yes
and so with January 6th I I believe
there is a strong probability that they
did want this to happen
Trump claims he wanted more security and
Pelosi didn't get it look man I've said
it before if on I think it was what May
29th 2020 the the Insurrection at the
White House if Trump ordered the police
to stand down he would be president
right now because these these people the
Democrats they understand politics they
understand public perception if the far
left ripped down the fencing at the
White House stormed into the building
and set fire to it and started doing a
whole bunch of them because they burned
a guard post and a church I assume they
said fire to the White House and Trump
went to the bunker
he would come out the next day and say
the far left extremists have been waging
a war on this country for months and
something needs to be done about it I am
calling on the governors of these states
and the mayor of D.C to take the action
acquired
instead
the police came in made the arrests
fired tear gas cleared people out and
the media came out and said Donald Trump
is a fascist which is so crazy because
if he had cracked down and called on
people to start cracking down that would
be like what Phil was talking about
earlier the fascist response to the
Communist uh meddling and he doesn't
have that fascist bone in his body he's
not that kind of guy he's like a a
liberal businessman he's not instead we
get the inverse on January 6th where
when a bunch of people show up some guy
for some reason keeps telling everybody
to go in the building and they keep
calling him a Fed he then Whispers In
some guy's ear who tears a barricade
down and then when the bumbling goddards
show up the cops fan them in open the
doors and give guided tours the
Democrats withhold the evidence and
claim it was an Insurrection for months
to to years now to yeah going on years
and they're going to try and use that
fortunately with Republicans squeaking
by a tiny Victory this stuff comes out
and Tucker Carlson is able to
definitively prove Democrats lied about
it all I will say it again proof Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt presented by Tucker
Carlson reposted by us about half an
hour later the police giving a guided
tour and even opening the doors for the
Q Shaman completely exonerating him and
proving Democrats lied about completely
everything do you think it's going to
make a difference
well the challenge is when it comes to
his criminal case
if this was being tried in say like a
state jurisdiction thing and this
evidence was withheld by the federal
government it probably would exonerate
them but the fact that it is the federal
government withholding the evidence and
Prosecuting him I don't think he's going
to get anything but why was it withheld
why was that not made available
because they're evil Ian so I mean but
legally how is it why was it withheld
they just don't have to show their own
evidence they said the American
public
section please that doesn't sound legal
they they are the ones who are sitting
on the footage and they say for security
reasons we won't give it out was it 14
000 hours of such a sham 44.
everything they can to portray a certain
agenda that's all they care about like
not good I think realistically that they
will be satisfied with this process
being the punishment for these people
being led around and let into the
building
um beyond that I'm not sure how someone
could sleep at night thinking this guy
was led around exactly here's here's
what I'll do if uh if I were to ever
become president I would run on the
campaign of criminally charging the
members of the January 6 committee for
withholding evidence that left and that
left innocent people in jail
and this is all
they don't want Trump to be president
so they would rather throw innocent
people young people that have their
whole lives ahead of them under the bus
just to make Trump look bad
yeah there are there are there are bad
people there are people on January 6 who
are fighting that's bad those people
should be charged but when you've got
evidence being withheld as to what
really happened by democrats and then
lying like Adam Schiff lying about Trump
and Russia at a certain point there's
got to be some kind of like use of
public office for the purpose of
defrauding the American people as a
criminal charge or something
I mean I have hope that there's that
there's possible charges that can be
filed I hope that there's lawsuits that
can be filed by uh private individuals
I'm hoping that we still have a judicial
system that works uh I know that it it
does to at least some extent right
because if not
Kyle Rittenhouse wouldn't be free if it
was completely and totally you know
thrown away here's my proposal for Vivek
ramaswam he talked about I think
arresting fauci and and um uh mayor
Garland was it arresting or removing I
mean maybe he said firing I don't think
he said arrest I'd I'd probably want
charges I will I will do this
um in my hypothetical presidential
campaign I will campaign on setting up a
gigantic bulletproof Plexiglas structure
that you can see through in DC where I
will go inside of it and start issuing
executive orders for the arrest and
prosecution of people like fauci Merit
Garland and all of the Democrats who
said in the j6 committee for defrauding
the American people fauci for instance
in an email
commissioned a study to debunk the Wuhan
lab League Theory why well to protect
himself because he's the one who gave
the money to dashik these people have
committed in my opinion criminal fraud
against the American people do we have
that story of fauci uh and I want to
know who he commissioned to do this
story that uh lab leak here it is from
the New York Post new emails show Dr
Anthony fauci commissioned scientific
paper in February 2020 to disprove Wuhan
lab leak Theory the they show he
prompted or commissioned and had final
approval on a scientific paper written
specifically in February 2020 to
disprove the theory the virus leaked
from a lab in Wuhan China eight weeks
later he stood at a White House Press
Conference alongside Trump citing that
paper as evidence that the lab leak
theory was implausible
so basically that is evidence of fauci
covering up malfeasance
gain of function research was being done
under his watch and he commissioned a
cover-up that is a definitive fact he
should be in prison
is Trump going to lock him up I don't
think he will is DeSantis no he won't so
who do we get to vote for who's going to
promise as part of their campaign to
arrest fauci at the very least Merrick
Garland should be completely removed
arresting him is a stretch the January 6
committee members who withheld
exculpatory evidence they should be
criminally charged as well you'd
probably want to not say you're going to
arrest fauci and when you get into
office just a rest of day one no no no
don't tell him you're coming campaign on
it and to be honest with you you should
talk about we should talk about that
kind of stuff all the time leading up to
the election because whoever actually is
the nominee nominee for the Republicans
that should be something that is
discussed openly and regularly and you
know what I'd say I'd be on that debate
stage and I'd say that's a very fine
question you got there moderator I just
want to add Anthony fauci you better
leave the country now and go somewhere
that doesn't have an extradition tree
with the United States because day one
you're getting locked up I would
encourage him not to flee because he's
going to get locked up
they have to actually do it because the
whole Locker up thing and
well the whole Locker up thing was like
a whole campaigning talking point and I
do feel like Trump was a bit soft about
certain things because he was afraid of
looking like a fascist but like we've
seen now how the left play like he can't
he can't do that he's got to lock him up
for real I don't like running on the the
platform that you're going to lock up
your political opponents you know if
they say if it's illegal but if the
president does it it's not illegal like
the the guy had us oversight the guy can
make illegal things legal like that's we
kind of give that guy power to do that
he's the commander of the military he
wants to commit a drone strike he can do
it he doesn't have more power to make
illegal things legal he can kill an
American citizen with a drone strike
apparently yeah well that's illegal
Obama Obama is a murderer legal and
illegal at the same time Barack Obama
murdered a 16 year old American citizen
that is not in dispute his name was
Abdul Rahman al-alaki and he was
executed on the under the orders of
Barack Obama in a drone strike on a
civilian restaurant in Yemen a country
we are not at war with so if it happened
if you run on a platform of imprisoning
every military official and politician
that was involved in the death of a
civil billion you're going to be
constantly sending everyone to jail
that's why I said bulletproof Plexiglas
box in the courtyard so everyone can
watch but then when you get out of
office they're gonna have to block
they'll come for you and it's like yes
but it's great it's a cyclical uh
destruction destructive maybe if there
weren't so many cowards in government
who are like but I don't want to step on
anyone's toes because then they'll come
for me well the thing is maybe we don't
have these problems in the first place
Anthony fauci didn't just
commission a drone strike against one
American civilian he issued and lied and
covered up gained a function research on
one of the most panicked diseases ever
to strike the human race that he may
have been the progenitor of we know that
equal Health Alliance was involved in
the creation of this stuff and he was
funding or asking them to fund this
stuff for him here's what I would say
right now where we are we know that
fauci provided funding to equal Health
Alliance which provided resources and
funding to the Wuhan lab to gain a
function back coronaviruses and it seems
to uh I should say two agencies
intelligence agencies the FBI and the
department of energy have come out and
said lab leak is the most plausible and
it would seem that if a virus is uh its
epicenter is right next to a virus
Factory probably was the virus Factory
where it came from now the question is
was the virus that was released the
virus that was paid for by fauci
I don't know it seems also likely but
the fact that fauci paid for the
cover-up in my opinion and tried to
cover up and lied about it he denied
being involved in the study that to me
reportedly that to me is Criminal to an
attempt to defraud the American people
and cover up political corruption and
malfeasance he should be locked up for
that and you know he was asked in my my
guesstimate is that someone was like hey
don't let anyone know Tony now's your
time whoever it was someone's like we
don't want to cause Panic we don't want
to blow the cover on Wuhan lab but that
still I mean at some point you know
what's his name the German pilot that
was the Nazi number three you know the
guy I'm talking about he hung they they
got he he met his end at the Nuremberg
trials he was like just one of the Nazis
but he was like one of the top Nazis
um Goring Hermann Goring is his name
so I I think prosecution is on Anthony
fauci's Horizon he's done us very dirty
and and the people around him did US
dirty and if you guys have have dibs on
him send it out blow it out blow the
whistle on this guy don't don't go down
with him
legitimate thing to go after him for
then do it but like how they're trying
to go after Trump on
make-believe things just because they
wanted to
you know get Trump what what ever
happened with that with the I wanna I
wanna sorry just issue a correction I I
believe I had read before that he was
asked if he was involved with the paper
and he denied it but now I think all
it's saying is that he never admitted
the paper he was citing was commissioned
by him he commissioned it he signed off
on it and then he cited it as if it was
real right that's right that's so dirty
and a position of authoritative power
administrative Force the highest paid
doctor in the country in 2019 or with
2020 the highest paid
uh politic political uh administrator in
the country both doctor and a Ministry
of some of 440 000 like this guy has
been around for 40 years doing this and
he sold us out he in his behavior and
his desire to decide with big Pharma put
this country on a death spiral I I don't
know what else to say he he is response
he was
I I'm all about forgiveness but I will
forgive him in a prison cell like he can
go to prison and and think of war or
whatever I I don't know the punishment
that's not up to me he can be charged he
can be arrested for a suspicion of lying
to the public I don't know what the
crime exactly would be conspiracy
defrauding the American people from a
position of government but the thing is
like when you're in the government
Authority the CIA they're expected to do
that they're expected to undermine the
American people every curve and we let
and we like give them carte blanche to
do it that's part of that he's not he's
the director of the niaid or was but in
a global pandemic situation it's like
habeas corpus is off the table like
that's why okay then fine then in
cleaning up the mess habeas corpus is
off the table right
if Anthony fauci gets a freebie then so
do I when I arrest them that's the thing
if he gets a freebie then the next time
this happens there will be another guy
that gets a freebie we can't let this
keep happening right so that means one
elected president I get the same freebie
he got and that means I get to arrest
him
I thought you should go to jail and
there should be a closed caption TV in
his uh in his cell that ran with Rand
Paul on the other end whenever he feels
like it just mocking him just giving him
credit so realistically it should be he
should be investigated at this stage
yeah yes I don't know like I said I
don't know what the what the uh the
actual charger should be someone tweeted
at me that it should be dereliction of
Duty which maybe that's that's
reasonable again I don't know but there
should be an investigation
I mean even if he's just like fired and
loses his pension that should be without
question
um I don't know man we're so far beyond
watching these Terror attacks letting
these people just do these things the
January 6th thing to me is it's it's
it's it's bordering on seditious
undermining the constitutional rights of
the American people and I'm pretty sure
there is already a crime on the books
that if you use an office of government
to undermine the Constitution then you
are guilty of a sphere of a felony I
believe we brought it up on the show
before someone linked it to us so if
they are sitting members of Congress the
federal government and they have denied
this man as due process rights by
withholding evidence I would argue
they've broken the law so uh you know
Liz Cheney
Raskin the whole lot I have no problem I
have no problem with throwing
politicians in jail I have zero problem
with that but we gotta investigate one
step at a time because if we just start
screaming for ju for like the punishment
that's a big that's not the direction we
want to investigate the situation if
they are found criminally liable then or
at least it looks like it then we'll
indict them or I suppose charge them and
then potentially indict them suppose the
good news for everybody is you can
simply show that video to your cult
member friends and family though they
won't believe it anyway it's real he was
let in he was led around he thanked the
cops for being so cool they'll make some
excuse the talking circles about it yep
they'll say look I don't have the answer
because I'm not a cult leader but the
cult leader says shut up so you should
shut up
that's it with with uh
I got a guy's name again Jacob Jacob
chancelly I don't know I got optimism on
this one because I think if if someone's
gonna let go get let go it's this guy
they've already let go a few people when
the evidence becomes purported yeah one
guy got exonerated on every charge
because there's a video of the cop
Fanning him into the building and the
judge was like that cop told him to come
in he's not trespassing one guy tried
claiming it and there's a video of him
climbing like over a broken barrier and
he's like he says no TR your trespassing
it says not to do what you're doing
you're doing it you know what I mean
like nice try buddy but for a lot of
these people who are walking around you
know we talked to the guy they call him
Podium guy even though what he picked up
was a lectern they lied about all of it
you know this guy was like he didn't
even know what's going on half these
people were just bumbling around direct
that old lady with the flag so I'm
trying to think the argument against uh
Jake uh chansley would be if he's on the
steps of the building then he's
technically as he begun trespassing if
it was trespassing to be in the building
on the steps is that considered
trespassing outside stuff yeah on the
outside the issue is that on any given
day you can go to the buildings walk in
right but since it was a protest we're
gonna do it this week would it be
considered trespass because if it was
already considered trespassing then
maybe the cops were like we're just
gonna keep this guy peaceful we're going
to keep him close by he's already been
locked him out of the building
peacefully it was one guy with nine cops
could have but like if someone's in the
process of committing a crime and the
cops see it they don't have to stop him
they can like watch and make sure things
don't get out of hand and then bust them
at the end if they want I think so maybe
they'll use that argument he was already
trespassing we were just there to watch
and figure out how to let him in they
were letting him into different room
after room show them how to get in come
on man there's like imagine it's like a
guy who's unarmed is in a bank and let
me show you where the vault is come with
me and then you bring up the Vault like
is Rob in the bank yeah like he's
waiting for after he robs the bank to
like put him under it'd be funny if
there was audio and it's chancelly like
walking up to the door and knocking and
the cops open he's like you got a
bathroom I can use like yeah come with
me and they walk him into the Senate
chamber and he's like hey and then they
arrested him right because if cop lets a
bank robber into the Vault they're an
accomplice unless they arrest him before
they leave I guess AOC said it that
there were cops who had let help some of
these people so let's let me let me lay
it down for you for ocasio-cortez over
here huh she says there's a knock on the
door she hides in the bathroom terrified
thinking she's gonna die or whatever
because a guy goes where is she
where is she and so now that we know
that the cops were actually letting
these people in and giving them guided
tours that really changes the fabric of
her story quite a bit now it's like the
guided tour found her oh not to mention
her story happened an hour before anyone
breached the building so that's also
kind of weird but uh yeah she's she's
making it up she's the she I really
really think that she just tells the
most embellished stories and I'm being
extremely polite by using that kind of
uh terminology oh they're all evil man
yeah like there's there's a handful of
Republicans who are not evil and then
most the Republicans are evil and most
the Democrats are evil all of them evil
that's such a strong oh okay what what
what word would you use to describe a
group of people who withhold evidence
that would exonerate a guy who's been
locked up in solitary confinement
not evil they're just torturing a guy
manipulative for sure and that's not
evil dude that's not even well there's
that situation could be used in a
non-evil way like in there are
situations where the villain is so
egregious that you're like we're gonna
make sure that he's not out here because
he's gonna you're saying nothing you're
saying that you'd have evidence you'd
have evidence exonerating the villain
proven no no not and you'd withhold it
to punish the guy because people think
he is that's not evil too
no that's yeah that's what the villain
does the villain
accuses the good guy of being the bad
guy withholds the evidence to prove him
wrong and locks him up so that's evil
who had this evidence is it just the
chair or was it the entire committee the
whole committee and they wouldn't
release it and also Pelosi would not
allow I think it was Jim Jordan and who
else that they uh um was it gosar maybe
no maybe not I don't know they wanted to
get some Republicans on the committee
and they said no and they said we'll get
Republicans they got kenzinger and
Cheney who are basically just Democrats
straight up yep or the New York
right
evil
if there's a if there's a if there's a
way to define what evil is it is that an
innocent man being besmirched and
imprisoned and you know it and you don't
care because the lie empowers you it's
really hard to accept that our
government could have turned as evil as
the Nazis had like I was like it just
seems like complete impossibility but
it's not
it could it could there is there is
nothing that makes
people today any different or less
susceptible to ideologies like Nazism or
communism Than People 50 or 100 years
ago the people that were Nazis in the
30s like Germany was like thought of as
the Pinnacle of philosophy and educated
people and progress progress they were
yeah they were they were like Cutting
Edge all of the rock star philosophers
from like the 1800s Engineers yeah most
of them were from were German Hegel was
German Marx was German uh There Was You
Know tons of them can't German all these
people were German philosophers so
Germany had this really really really
high esteem in the early part of the
20th century and
so to think that that it was dumb people
that were backwards that were duped by
the Nazis that is not the case at all
they were intelligent they were that
they were completely and totally
Cosmopolitan so you can't just look back
and say oh well they were just dumb you
have to give the bad guys the credit
that or credit enough to be to look at
them as actually intelligent because
that's why they're dangerous
and to your point like about not all
Democrats being bad I think it's the
same thing where there's the upper level
of the Nazis that did know they were
evil as stim says evil and they knew
what was going on and they totally went
in for that but I think that there were
some Nazis that had good intentions and
they didn't know what was going on and
that's the individual thing to look at
like you were talking about the
Democrats I was thinking about Hillary
Clinton we came we saw he died
yeah I was doing some more Kamala Harris
and getting her buddy uh Cindy
Blumenthal weapons manufacturing deals
in Libya after the planned Invasion yeah
it's called evil yeah that's that that's
and it's like and justify the means
from the outside it looks evil that's
for sure just say it's evily and you say
it's evil I I can't I'm not God I can't
make that objective claim but it
definitely seems like it from where I'm
standing but you know imperialism maybe
has some value to it it just seems gross
but I'm also benefiting off of the the
economics of it so there's that I am all
about accountability for bad people
and the purpose of our classically
liberal government was to protect the
innocent and punish the guilty not not
the sole purpose but one of them was to
protect the innocent that's why we have
the Bill of Rights and the problem now
is evil people are doing exactly what we
thought was evil and fought against to
create a government that would protect
the innocent if you do not protect the
innocent your system collapses outright
it is a brilliant framing by the
founding fathers it's basically this
simple
if you have a government that says we
will punish uh I think it was Otto von
Bismarck who said it is better that 10
innocent people suffer than one guilty
person escape the reason that system
doesn't work is because if people feel
that even if they're innocent they will
be punished just be guilty then be a
criminal because you're screwed either
way but if the system says if you are
innocent we will do everything to
protect you then people have an
incentive to be good citizens and not
commit crimes
otherwise just falls apart if Thomas
Jefferson quote uh the tree of Liberty
must be refreshed from time to time with
the blood of easy tiger
I think people have pointed out that he
later said he was he was wrong to say
that and he was they walked him back
really with the blood of what yeah he
got Patriots and tyrants he's just
saying that always a country will turn
back to tyranny and people are gonna
have to fight
after after he tweeted that he got an
email from Franklin or something in
Europe yeah
um it's a it's a brutal quote he from a
brutal time Jefferson is you know LED
one of the greatest revolutions Ian what
would you describe give us an example of
what you would view as evil
uh hurting something to watch it suffer
that's that's it that's that's an
example that's the only that's the only
one grabbing a cat and just squeezing
its neck to watch it see how its face
changes okay squeezing it Tighter and
Tighter slowly so you don't think that's
what they were doing to this Shaman guy
by withholding the evidence keeping him
locked in the case no I I don't know
what confinement is considered torture I
I don't think it was to watch him suffer
I think it was for their own agenda
that's what that's what I think it was
for okay how about would you consider it
evil if someone squeezes a cat to death
for 10 bucks yeah okay so what if these
people withheld evidence leaving a man
to be tortured because it got them
better salaries kept them in positions
of power
yeah I think if they start throwing
innocent people under the bus for power
yeah that's literally what they did
January there's tons of innocent people
in the January that are being held
without without charges and if you don't
charge them and you don't try them
they're innocent because they're
innocent until proven guilty you said 44
000 hours that's what I heard and that
that would be because there's so many
cameras it's not it's right you know
it's like my guess is that they didn't
see all of that I was gonna say did they
see the footage there's no only way
possible to watch 24 000. the shaman I
guarantee you they all watched every
second of the shaman footage they knew
this guy was being brought in by the
cops and I supported I also assumed that
in the 44 000 hours there are you know
there are corridors where no one went
down that quarter all day so though so
that if no one went down there you don't
need to watch it or or they fast fast
forward you know like so they probably
watched a good portion of it and he
probably had a bunch of people doing it
but it wasn't like that just like eat
popcorn and they're all watching it
together I would hope so they definitely
got a doordash or something you know I
wonder if the chair was deciding what
they saw I don't know how it works in
those in those uh Chambers if they're
like we're gonna We're not gonna show
certain pieces of footage to the council
because we need to make a decision that
I want to go my way so you're going to
see what I want you to see if that's the
case who's seeing it first to make that
decision I would imagine the head of the
the head of the chair the chair of the
committee
um if that is the case and the chair of
the committee is deciding what's good
scene that's a gross misjustice and that
they should serve right time for that or
at least be charged for uh misleading
the public or something like that
misleading the the committee if if they
all saw it and they were all like well
this is going to get the guy off and
make him innocent so we can't show it
then they're all guilty that's that's I
mean that's egregious you can't that's
that's a mishandling of justice and it
shouldn't happen it shouldn't happen all
the people we should look every every
possible
piece of evidence that shows any of
these people are innocent should be
brought to attention immediately because
the the most important thing is that the
innocent ones are let out yeah
then we can deal with all the danger and
the damage
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com go there because uh that's
how we sustain this operation it's how
we're in business it's how uh we do
everything that we do our customers are
not big sponsors for the most part we do
sponsor in the podcast our customers are
you and it's a pay what you will model
so
we're just hoping that more and more
people who watch decide to give us 10
bucks a month to watch the after show
and then we don't have to worry about I
don't know selling
supplements or something but to be
honest we'll probably make our own
because I really want to do my own
protein MCT blend stuff for when after
you finish a skate and you want all that
energy or maybe right before but that's
the point man I'd rather just have more
members and less sponsors all of these
big companies want us to take on a
million and one sponsors because we
would make I think I think we have these
companies come to us and they're like
you will make 10 times the money you
make right now if you do six ads per
episode no joke they want us to do ad
reads at the beginning of the show 15
minutes 30 45 live and I'm like dude I'm
not doing that breaks of the
conversation is not fun and they're like
yeah but you've got this natural flow
sign this deal with us and I'm like nah
dude I'm just going to keep hoping that
we get more members but it's a reality
we've made more money if I just did ad
reads I just don't want to all right
we'll read some more Super chats from
you guys and we're gonna have that
members only show coming up at about 10
10 p.m it will go live and that is what
you get
with your uh 10 membership but also you
know what else I'm gonna say
Thursday is my birthday so this whole
week I'm gonna say if you want to give
me a birthday present just present just
become a member at timcast.com and watch
the after show and you can watch me
swear a whole lot and that's a birthday
present so uh it's gonna be fun you're
gonna be fun birthday I'll be 37 years
old I am I am halfway there all right
I'm not your buddy guy says hey Tim did
you get around to watching Douglas
Murray nuke the mainstream media from
orbit at the monk debates in Toronto if
so what did you think I didn't did
anybody see that no
nope
all right let's see Wayback says Tim
have you seen the krasenstein saying on
Twitter that they aren't an organized
group of antiva members like the right
claims the krasensteins I believe at
this point are actually just making
leftist tweets for the right like I
don't think people on the left actually
read what the Crescent scenes say I
think conservatives read what the
Crescent seeds say and view them as the
left but they're actually pretending to
be a caricature of the left to get
right-wing views because it benefits
them controlled opposition no no no it's
just like
they're they're PR they're they're
pretending to be the villain
so because conservatives will watch what
they say and give them clicks and make
them money and the Liberals probably
don't watch what they say so he's still
in the payroll right they still get into
the DNC pay them to tweets though or did
they I don't know if they ever did okay
I don't think so they got banned if they
didn't and then in my apologies yeah I'm
like I was reading some like all their
articles are just crafted based off
right-wing talking points to be
inversions of them and I'm like liberals
aren't talking about this stuff like
Liberals are talking about you know
whatever this I can't remember what
issue the left was talking about but the
crisis were talking about a right wing
talking point from the inverted position
and I'm like I think they're making this
content for the right not the left just
to get them all riled up again I mean
it's brilliant if that's what they're
doing you know be be like it's like on
The View they have that Republican woman
she's not really a republican she's just
like this is the McCain one or no she's
gone uh what's her name fair or
something or whatever I don't know
someone look it up
all right let's see what we got
Max Redick says Tim would you consider
getting the krasensteins back on the
show I think they should be pressed on
how they feel about child drag
performances their Twitter just screams
cult mentality
oh yeah that's it's it's all sophistry
they're like drag it's not a sexual
performance and it's like okay look
we'll talk about this in the members
only show because we have Martina here
and she knows all about it yeah I can't
wait to get into it I know I'm like I'm
gonna bring it up and then we're gonna
have to open up Pandora's box but
there's so much there to break down
obviously stuff I've talked about but
we've got someone with real experience
and we've got a really creepy video of
children dancing taking money from
strangers and adult men and like we're
not gonna play it because it's not
family friendly but it'll be on the
members show so again go to timcast.com
become a member for my birthday and it
would be a very great birthday present
to have you watch the after show and and
join us in our mission I would love to
see the crass and scenes here I would
love to see I know but I mean I didn't
get to be on the show I didn't get to
talk to him I just talked to him down
the Green Room a little bit I would love
to be able to push back on some of their
ridiculous comments
all right John Mayer says still comfy
and cozy in the middle or do you have
the same balls as the men who explored
and Built America which Tim pool are you
today the one who's like basically in
the middle in terms of I won't make
assertions without evidence but uh it's
funny when there's like the meme of milk
toast fence sitting when like if we were
going to be actually honest I get loud
and angry about a lot of issues free
speech gun rights like how is it milk
toast fence setting to tell a a
Congressional candidate a gubernatorial
candidate that we should allow people
have the right to nuclear weapons and
and biological weapons because arms are
our arms biological weapons and nuclear
arms our arms and if you want to change
that rule you change the Constitution
pretty sure that's not fence sitting
pretty sure that's like one of the more
extreme viewpoints in terms of American
politics on weapons
Constitution says the right keeping bear
arms it doesn't say which ones
anyway all right let's let's get some
more
Jimmy Joe says Martinez JJ I called
flambos as soon as I saw you on here he
says he's proud of you me too congrats
oh my God flambo no way well there you
go
former performer fire performer people
and it's really nice to see that there's
still some people that support and it's
not just a blanket like screw her that's
awesome cam girl as soon as says Tim I
love your content but you really need to
have an actual discussion in the merits
of War at this point I am sick and tired
of your refusal to understand that we
need to respond with Force if we want
freedom to endure
but Define force the issue is we're in a
fifth generation we're in fifth
generational Warfare and they've
subverted our institutions to gain power
and manipulate people and where we're at
a time where physical Force I don't
believe is as effective as manipulative
psychological Force which is why that's
what we see a lot of in fact this terror
attack by antifa is one of the worst
things for them this could actually be
evidence that could wake people up to
the psychological manipulation that's
why I always say violence isn't the
answer you have to be subversive look
man I'll put it this way
you got the the Samurai and the ninja
tropes the samurai marching with honor
and striking from the front and the
ninja sneaking in and the wee hours of
the morning and removing their
leadership and then they wake up and
they have no command structure which one
was more effective well they both have
their merits right but sometimes
subversion is the the appropriate method
I think right now with fifth
generational Warfare you need to win
over hearts and Minds with cultural
influence and create a space that is
more positive and enjoyable
they they're vulnerable there that's
their weakness it is it is painful to
exist on the left because you're always
at fear of being canceled we need to
figure out how to create a bigger space
so that people feel I'm gonna chill and
have a beer and ain't nobody gonna yell
at me if I'm over on this side
all right let's see we got Fire Sky says
we have to make make it be terrarium
I don't know what that means but thank
you for the Super Chat I think where is
it that training you're
you're glass
maybe well this was from earlier in the
show I think he's talking about the
antifa the copsite look like sea lemon
make it an anti-faturarium no idea no
idea
all right Nathan Jones says the thing in
Atlanta is an Insurgency yeah maybe but
antifa's bigger than that to me like
Insurgency would be a small faction from
one area rising up with arms and causing
chaos yeah that you can't find that's
like in it and it's stuck it's like with
woven in the community these people came
from from Canada well one guy from
Canada
yeah like they're they're all wearing
black one of them worked for the
Southern Poverty Law Center
like dude you don't get to break on into
a government facility with a bunch of
people burning it down and then be like
I'm just here to watch well that's great
you're under arrest you're terrorist
that's ridiculous look man I get it we
we have leeway for to a certain degree
journalists but uh even even journalists
understand
you go into a war zone ain't nobody's
gonna stop and go wait wait hold your
fire they're with journalists
that doesn't matter so that's that's
that's the risk you you you endure and I
know journalists who have been captured
detained and tortured and beaten up
because they don't care in fact you're a
journalist that means you got
information you you are a part of that
it shouldn't be but I but I also want to
say this with the splc they are not
neutral actors they are not journalists
this was the legal defense apparatus it
was a political weapon to protect their
terror attack yep the definition of
insurgent would be a person who revolts
against civil Authority or an
established government uh especially a
rebel not recognized as a belligerent so
kind of like a non-violent no no no no
no no no no no no no no no that's what
this stuff is that's not saying
non-violent that's not what it means
it's a belligerent not a religion a
non-belligerent or our insurgents are
usually considered non-belligerent for
some reason according to this definition
I would think that violent Insurgent
people would still be considered
insurgents and by definition they could
anyone revolting against civil Authority
or an established government it's very
vague that's a very vague term it's
probably made vegan on purpose so that
they could bust people on Insurgency
crimes and stuff
all right the great baguette says in the
video game Hearts of Iron IV they depict
the Spanish Civil War in a land power
grab between the factions leading up to
the Declaration
I watched a great documentary in the
Spanish Civil War a long time ago that's
why I like to bring it up because what I
learned from there as from that as much
as I don't know a whole lot about it is
simply American's view of civil war is
weird and makes no sense most countries
don't have this kind of state factional
system and our version of a Civil War
was not the same it was a portion of the
country trying to break it it was the
country breaking itself in half whereas
typically a civil war is when two or
more factions fight over control of one
government
so shout out to Hearts of Iron 4 one of
the only Grand strategy simulation games
I've ever seen that actually uses Hitler
as a character that you can play as
pretty really yeah if you want to play
as the Nazi Germans you can wow that's a
great shout out Paradox
most video games they won't even show
the swastikaans they canceled Hitler
it's crazy SIV like a civilization
series doesn't like doesn't have Hitler
ever that's not crazy it's nuts he was
the greatest and I use great in terms of
like scope and scale not not good or
evil but he was known as a great
leader in history evil yes but like
Genghis Khan was a great leader you know
probably word things better he was uh
what's what's a um what's it let's get
let's get a war that means evil and and
you know unfortunately evil people are
remembered as great people but that's
because the history books are written by
them this guy we actually video cameras
I think the issue is just the context of
the word great typically implies a
positivity yeah but it's a scope and
scale is the but it could also mean
massive Ian sounds like a griper to me
tonight
hold on yes if you're playing a video
game about war on Earth and it's
simulating war and they removed Hitler
that is the that is woke cult psychosis
they were Stalin in the game he's in
some Civ games uh Mal
oh Mao for sure yeah I'm pretty sure Mao
was in Civ yes he is the the idea that
you would have people responsible for
the deaths of like 50 to 100 million
people in the game shows you the
ideological manipulation
all right we'll read some more Super
chats so that you know we can move on
from Ian referring to Hitler as great I
love you and you got it baby
oh Lord all right Hayden 75 says Crowder
just uploaded the video and is back
March 20th awesome I saw he's with
Patrick Bet David on the valuetainment
podcast and he made a big announcement
he's going to be starting a network
where he's going to bring in new talent
and I don't know much more about it than
that but he's going to be launching
people's careers as far as I know they
went deep on the show sounds good
all right
let's read some more Super chats
Adrian Curry says did you ever think we
would live to see the day that Rocky
Horror Picture Show is as tame as a
Church sermon is that the Adrian Curry
it is the one and only oh my God hi
she's in the chat like she's in the chat
everyone I love it hi let me take your
portrait she has she has basic takes we
like to throw that out there she's great
yeah shout out
it is kind of crazy that uh you've got
even churches
joining the cult that's the weirdest
thing
yeah yeah well I don't get that too
because like the
Christianity they always talk about
it you know what they hate more than
that they oh okay you're talking about
the because I was going to say the the
religious people hate empty pews and
that's why they are right right no but
the left and like they're always calling
them the pedophiles and like pointing
out like oh oh well Christianity you
know the pedophiles and it's like what
are you doing pandering to these people
Mr Jarvis in the member chat says Tim
needs to call for justice for Ashley
Babbitt agreed 100 and the more we learn
about her story The the crazier it is I
mean the left should be all over this a
cop shot an unarmed woman nope they
don't care these people are now that we
have more evidence suggesting that many
of these people were innocent and even
LED in by the police
you we definitely need uh justice so
you know I guess that means vote Trump
but I'm not even 100
that uh
Trump is gonna get the job done Adrienne
curry in the member chat says Adrienne
Curry is a drag performer from the 1970s
so you were named after the track she
also she also says hello pretty lady to
you oh oh that's awesome I'm like
totally fangirling now what would
Justice for Ashley Babbitt look like is
it just an investigation an
investigation and probably some kind of
criminal charges for the cop who shot
her for sure a civil suit I know that we
talked definitely definitely uh with
Taylor
um
we talked about the civil suit with
Taylor Hansen and people have been
tweeting to clarify and talk to some of
my Gerhart Fox I don't know how involved
you are with everything Gerhart but I
saw the Tweet here's a falcon lady says
Robert Silverman The Daily Beast
journalist who's written hit pieces on
Tim and Andy no tweeted on December 5th
2022 that he's in charge of Brooklyn
antifa yes there is a growing terrorist
faction around the country that we've
long known about and every winter people
seem to forget they exist because these
people are scared of the cold
it's true though it's true they don't go
out when it's cold out it starts getting
warm so you're seeing this now because
it's been unseasonably warm it's been
been great you know we had um it's crazy
it's the craziest thing happened a bunch
of white powder fell from the sky in
this area and landed all over cars this
weird soot and residue and dust and then
it blew away but left some waxy
substance behind and everybody was
freaking out but don't worry they said
it was pollen
in February just polishing from the
trees in February which is winter he had
like a 78 it's possible we had a 78
degree day and then it was like three to
four days later or so even less than
that it blew in that happened once in
New York in one day I lived up on top of
um Cypress Hill in New York City in in
Brooklyn and let's one day the wind came
and just took all this pollen into my
apartment and coated the surfaces with
this yellow green
let's ask the audience
um we'll ask the audience is it uh more
likely that a pollen storm happened uh
just after a massive train derailment
chemical burn off and toxic soot being
blast into the sky which is uh uh
downwind from this area the wind is
blowing towards this area and uh all
that happened and then at the same time
it got unseasonably warm for a long
enough period of time that spring
started a month early a month and a half
early and the trees in the PLA and the
plants all blossomed blasting a mass
amount of pollen throughout the air or
is it more likely the government lied
hmm government lied Interest come on
there's no there look the grass is still
stunted the only thing growing right now
is the chives and that makes me very
happy because they're delicious they're
everywhere all over the yard I love
picking them up rinse them off eating
them we put them in the cheese dip oh
it's so good put them on your beef
they're good have you eaten them no not
yet not this season but they're yeah
they're everywhere we put them in the
beef make tacos delicious but uh nothing
else is growing there's no there's no
leaves everywhere where's the pollen
coming from well it was weird we had
like one day at 80 degrees and then it's
been 35 every day pretty much since then
it's been like 60. yeah I got up to 50
today 51 or something I was 60. I
checked it oh wow it's 52 right now yeah
no snow it didn't I don't think it
snowed one time
it it it okay there was like a day where
it was like almost snow but it didn't
stick and then like one day I woke up
and the ground was Frozen For the First
Time and then that was it
we went snowboarding everything was
brown except for the fake Snow Trails
and it's just kind of gross but you know
it's it's still fun you get snow here
uh La I mean two years ago we got a lot
of snow we went snowboarding outside
because we it's like a hill we're like
we're on top of a mountain and you could
snowboard down and we were uh really
excited just didn't snow at all this
year
yeah really weird yeah we had snow
recently actually just the other day we
had no snow so weird yeah
it's almost like you know the planet is
warming up or something you know maybe
maybe like the temperature like
something with the global
fire yeah Global heating yeah climate
climate climate alteration changes I
just when I was just at home in New
Hampshire this past weekend and I paid
my Dr my plow guy a thousand dollars and
I'd already given him 600 bucks so we
got snow up there I don't know what's
going on down here we got no snow down
here
all right let's grab some more super
jets Steven says says a lot of evidence
points to federal agents being the
violent ones on January 6th
yeah yeah like video of them beating on
the protesters
all right s f v Raiders has shout out to
my nephew pooters 14 years passed away
on Saturday at an off-road event here in
SoCal was crashed into an accident
please send prayers to his father and
family glad to hear it man yeah
yes love her Steve says in general a
Brady violation occurs when a prosecutor
fails to provide a defendant a criminal
defense or criminal defense attorneys
with evidence that is favorable or
helpful to a defendant's case
so how do we get this guy out of jail
now that we have video showing the
police let him in
that's a crazy video man let's keep
talking there they go to a door and try
to open it they can't and they're like
follow me and he's following the cops
walking through a bunch of cops and they
open the door we were in those buildings
there are cops everywhere could you
imagine if we like we're going to the
Capitol Building and they were like you
weren't supposed to be in there we'll be
like we walked to the front door and the
cops let us in and then told us where to
go and they were like nope Insurrection
we should bring the evidence with us on
Friday this should be a topic of the
conversation we have with Matt because
if they don't know yet in Congress we
should Enlighten everybody oh he knows
yeah it Matt Matt's been talking about
it for a long time he even he even
suggested that feds were involved in in
all of this so this is going to be a
heck of a conversation with Matt later
this week and all that they're probably
saying let's go go in there my deepest
conspiracy mine is is on mute for this
show usually but yeah I'm with you but I
mean sorry I don't know much about it
um so is he being held and he has like
his a lawyer
so I mean like if it's like a public
defender I bet that'll be but if
he's got like a decent lawyer that that
should be really good for him
yeah I don't know
he has civil disorder obstruction uh
he's currently locked up right
proceeding entering and remaining in a
restricted building yeah uh he's got a
lot of charges here that's crazy
demonstrating is a charge what picketing
parading is a charge
demonstrate picketing in a capital
building disorderly and disruptive
content conduct in a restricted building
violent entry and disorderly violent
entry all right
dude I don't know if he's still in I
would imagine he's still being held if
but I'll look into it
41 months in prison friend of squirrel
oh he was already convicted that was
like two years ago yeah a year and a
half ago 41 months friend of squirrel
says the squirrels I film every day in
my YouTube shorts are smarter than Ian
by the way Rusty Cage recently built
something to solve our fauci problem
hahaha rusty cage is fantastic by the
way big fan he's a funny guy we had him
out here for a cast Castle episode where
um it's a very old episode but the gag
is due to some incidents at the castle
we there's there's a rush to find
someone who can give sexual harassment
trainings to to avoid the liability and
then uh my brother calls Rusty Cage
famous YouTuber but uh and and the joke
he goes hey Rusty didn't you say uh well
I'm gonna ruin the joke he says uh
didn't you say you could write a book on
sexual harassment and he's like I said I
I know I ruined the joke I remember he
says uh I did write a book on sexual or
something like that and then what
happens is Rusty comes out and he's
asked to give sexual harassment training
but he doesn't train people on how not
to he literally trains them how to
sexually harass that's the joke it's
funny he's great yeah
all right let's uh let's read some more
yeah you guys should watch the cast
Castle stuff the next episode's gonna be
really funny we're trying to work out
these jokes because we've got some
really good ones but crafting it to a
bigger narrative is more difficult
we're going to shoot a scene this week
I'll tell you about it later it's gonna
be good it's gonna be good oh yeah all
right all right let's grab some more
Super chats we can get a couple more in
here
Kellman telf says h o is that h o uh
Hearts of Iron four is also a World War
II simulation missing the leader of
Germany in a World War II simulation
would not make sense is that what it is
yeah yeah it starts in like 1935 or 36.
it's a World War II simulator without
Hitler in it no Hitler's in it that's
the one that Hitler's in he was saying
it would be weird if he wasn't oh there
are other video games oh you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right you're saying it was the
one game that did have the hearts of
iron I haven't played the other ones he
might be in the other ones too
so like there are games where you can
play as Stalin and just like Massacre
100 million people and
I mean to be honest civilization a video
game
like a coupon of the game is to take
cities over massacring people and then
force them into your like you have when
you take all these over these cities
they resist you and you basically force
them that Civilization that's the game
it's a component of it it's one of the
ways you win the game actually military
Victory no no no no no no no we can't
have any any and Politically Incorrect
all right all right
Cosmic surgeon says krasis would make
Phil look pathetic like wrestling a
gator underwater it's all theatrics they
straw man move goal posts parse your
argument no good faith argument you
always lose no that's not true when the
Crescent scenes came on here what I
found is that they couldn't actually
answer any of the questions or have a
real conversation with me because they
didn't know about what was going on so
when I brought up the cutter turkey
pipeline they're like I don't know what
that is and I said okay what about gas
problem I don't know what that is okay
what about Prisma I don't know what that
is and I'm like all right well if you
don't how are we supposed to have a
conversation on these issues but I can
respect that they're uh just ignorant of
many of these details which is why I
thought the show went well
but there you go
so we'll see
Kellen Shaw indie game says Tim
preemptive happy birthday my birthday is
tomorrow as someone almost exactly one
year older than me how should I spend my
next year as a 36 year old keep up the
good work you'll rate true inspiration
take vitamins and exercise
um I think taking vitamins is extremely
important and I never really thought
about it never really bothered but uh
vitamins I think was a really smart move
what kind do you take
so I take a multivitamin a vitamin C and
vitamin D I was going to recommend CoQ10
it's like a super antioxidants over the
counter but it's
I recommend it I'm looking it up right
now antioxidant I know there's this
thing as do having too many vitamins oh
yeah too much magnesium can be bad for
your kidney too much vitamin D is bad
for too much magnesium is called a um
uh
well I can't think of the word right now
it makes you poop or laxatives they
actually yeah good thing I was taking
some and it makes me nervous because I'm
pregnant and then I was like I just kept
taking it and then someone over the
counter was like should you be taking
I'm like I don't know should I not and
then I started looking it up and I got
concerned and I'm like oh my God you can
take too much magnesium yeah
oh yeah the judge says Elon needs to buy
CNN for cheap fire everyone hire people
like Glenn Greenwald Tim Matt taibi
Jimmy Dore Crowder go ham okay I that
might I that's tempting if Elon bought
CNN and then fired everybody and then
asked Glenn me Matt Jimmy Crowder to do
shows I if he can even said I would want
you to host a show on CNN I own it I
fight everybody I might do it
so they can run reruns on CNN well yeah
I'd say that how about you do this just
run IRL for two hours on CNN prime time
we'll take it over all those people who
watch all 10 of those people will get
you know I'm sure it'll be great for our
bottom line go live on CNN we get more
viewers than them already on cable yeah
but YouTube's propping them up so they
get more views on YouTube which is your
your fans would watch or the the viewers
here would go to CNN to watch absolutely
if you went over to CNN they would
follow you soon you don't think so no
way yeah the goal is so that the people
who watched it and blindly are forced to
watch this show well I think that would
happen too but the people who watch here
just watch here oh you're talking about
a few simulcast or something yeah I
would stop doing this show all right my
bad no I'm saying like if Elon came and
said do a show I'd be like you know
against I just license this one here air
this one there you go
what do we got Rebel Without a Cause
says power tends to corrupt and absolute
power corrupts absolutely great men are
almost always bad men Lord John Emerick
Edward Dahlberg Acton
Lord Acton said that Lord Acton great
men are almost always bad men that's an
interesting concept well you know
let's see what we got
let's grab a couple more of these here
super jets maybe just one more one more
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim you should
do the white Latino person wakanda so
California is trying to pass a law that
movies must have like cast and crew
representative of the demographics of
California which is like half white half
Hispanic including illegal immigration
well I don't know about that but the
point is this would mean that when they
made black panther all of the characters
would have to be 40 white 40 Hispanic
and you know eight percent black or
whatever so it's like welcome to wakanda
here's Cheech Marin our leader is it
just the crew they're just mandating the
crew the reason why they're doing more
like interracial gay relationship shows
is because they have tax requirements
so what they're trying to do is say if
you don't have gender sexual and racial
diversity you will not get a tax credit
so the movie does is say okay we'll do
the movie and then we'll add a scene
with uh like a white dude and a black
dude having a gay relationship so that
it checks all the boxes and then we get
our tax credit oh yeah that's so weird
anyway my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
and head over to timcast.com this is the
important part Thursday is my birthday
and if you'd like to give me a birthday
present go to timcast.com click join us
become a member and hang out uh watch
our members only shows we're gonna have
a members only show live at about 10 10
p.m it'll be on the front page of the
website it'll be very similar to this
but we'll swear a whole lot more and it
will not be very family friendly at all
we're going to talk about drag burlesque
and things like that what's going on
with kids and uh it's not going to be
not going to be good for the kids you
know so you don't want you know kids
should not be hearing this stuff
you the parents to decide and uh just
come hang out timcast.com smash the like
button you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at timcast Martina do you want to shout
anything out no I just want to say thank
you for having me and I'm sorry I get
super nervous so thanks for everybody
watching and you know being polite and
hopefully I didn't come across as a fool
but please follow me as well Martina
marcota
m-a-r-k-o-t-a
I am Phil that remains on Twitter I am
Phil that remains official on Instagram
uh give me a follow we'll yell at
commies I am at Ian Crossland on the
internet hit me up anywhere and
everywhere talk to you later
and I am at surge.com was a good one
thanks guys
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about 10 minutes
thanks for hanging out